-Good to see you, buddy.
-Great to see you, as always.
-Dude, congrats.
-Hey.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-They love you.
They love you.
We love you.
-I love you.
-I got a lot too --
I love me too.
[ Laughter ]
I want to get to the song.
-Yeah.
-But what a year you've had.
First of all,
can I just recap for you?
-Sure.
-This is what happened to you.
You were in "Jumanji"
and "Jumanji" made
almost $1 billion worldwide.
I don't know if you knew that.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Biggest movie.
Congratulations.
You were fantastic in it.
-Thank you. Thank you.
-Then you got nominated for a
Golden Globe for your song
in "Ferdinand."
And then even the best news, the
biggest news, the coolest news.
You got engaged to our buddy.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Priyanka Chopra.
♪♪
I've got to say, dude,
she is the most fun person.
We love her so much.
Priyanka Chopra.
-She's the best.
-How did you --
how did you meet?
-Well, we met through a friend.
So we got connected first
over text
and we started talking
for a while,
and it was about six months
before we met up in person.
And then we actually attended
the Met Gala
a few years ago together.
-Oh, yeah.
-Had a great time,
but it just --
-As friends.
-Just friends.
And our lives were kind of
taking us to different places.
And the thing that was funny,
is people would ask us,
both in an interview setting
and in private,
"Are you guys seeing
each other?"
And the answer was "No"
and people thought
we were being coy.
And so did we --
until we cut to now
we're engaged
so the story sort of
wrote itself.
-Yeah, like, oops. Yeah.
-But you know, we then met up
a couple months ago --
I think five months ago now,
and it was kind of immediate
and I think we just knew it
was right and jumped right in
and we're very happy.
-Oh, that's fantastic, dude.
I love that. I love her --
Please give her --
give her my best.
She's one of our favorites.
-She's here.
-Is she here?
-She's here right now.
-Is she in the crowd?
[ Cheers and applause ]
-She's over there.
-Ah! Hey, pal.
Hey, how are you?
Hi, hi, hi.
Oh. All right.
I mean -- I think.
I mean, I think she's okay.
[ Light laughter ]
Oops. Sorry.
You know I love you, pal.
Explain what this is about.
So, we -- Okay, so after we got
engaged, we then went to India,
to her home country
and to Mumbai.
And my parents came along
and we did this beautiful
Roka ceremony.
-What is that?
-Basically, it's a confirmation
from both sides of the family
that they approve
of the engagement.
And then there's some
beautiful prayers
and a connection just for the
family to have a chance to meet
and hang out and get
to know each other.
It's really incredible,
and you know,
we both left that ceremony
so full of joy.
-How did your family
handle that?
-They loved it.
My parents were blown away by
the love shared among
all the people.
And just the --
-a little different
than New Jersey.
-A little different than Jersey.
[ Light laughter ]
But it was really special and
for she and I,
I think it was just nice to be
able to have that time
with the family first.
And have that private moment.
And be able to share with
the world afterwards.
But it's funny that we had
this beautiful ceremony,
and we felt so connected,
and our families all met.
And it was spiritual.
And then we put it on Instagram.
And we were like, "Oh, my God,
it's official."
-Now we Instagram.
Now it's real.
Now they really have to do it.
Yeah.
Do you guys --
there's a nice picture
of the family there on
Instagram.
Now uh, NP -- is that your logo?
Is that a logo for your --
Do you guys have a celebrity
nickname?
-We --
-Priyanka, you can answer that.
Do you have a celebrity
nickname?
-She likes Prick.
[ Laughter ]
-No, no, no. Absolute no.
-I don't like that one.
-Absolutely no.
[ Laughs ]
I have to ask you this question
because it's one of
my favorite stories.
We were talking earlier today.
Thanks for doing the bit,
by the way.
-Oh, it was great.
I had a lot of fun.
-Love hanging out with you.
But you told me the story about
going to the Golden Globes
and it must have been exciting.
-Oh, gosh.
-I was like, "Was it exciting
for you?" And you go,
"yeah, I lost, but --"
just tell the story
'cause it's great.
-Well, I feel like every time
I come here
I tell you a really
embarrassing story by the way.
-Exactly.
And that's why --
And I love that you keep
coming back
and I keep making you
embarrass yourself.
-But it's sad that the first
thought I had
when something embarrassing
happens is,
"I got to talk to Jimmy."
[ Laughter ]
-Please, always do that.
Please.
-So, I'm at the Golden Globes.
I was very excited.
I was so honored to be nominated
for the song.
And it was a real career
milestone for me.
-Yeah.
-And I'm sitting in the audience
with my brother
who came with me.
And they announced
the award and we lost.
Or, I lost.
Me and my co-writers.
And I was devastated.
I was really hoping it would
happen and he said,
"Let's go to the bar,
let's grab a drink.
Blow off some steam for a minute
and we'll go back inside."
-Yeah.
-And so I go to
the bar with Joe.
I grab myself a beer,
and he gets one.
And I'm hanging out and I've
heard all this talk that
Michael Keaton is arriving soon.
People are whispering, "Michael
Keaton's coming over.
He's gonna come over."
And I'm thinking to myself,
"Wow, this is great. I'm so
excited to meet Michael Keaton."
-Yeah, I love Michael Keaton.
-And I've got my beer here
and there's a woman here trying
to take a picture of me and Joe.
And she bumps into us
as he approaches.
And the beer spills all over
Michael Keaton
just before he goes on stage
to present an award.
So cut to three
or four days ago,
we're at the U.S. Open.
-This is the best.
-And I kid you not.
I walk in, shuffling to our
thing with the beer,
and I see Michael Keaton.
It's like he locks eyes with me.
He's like --
[ Light laughter ]
"I hope you're not
drinking a beer."
-Yeah, you better
watch it Jonas."
-And I sat down.
-Yeah.
-I had the little bag on my
lap.
Put my beer on the ground,
and he's right here.
And the bag falls off
in slow motion.
[ Audience oohs ]
Hits the beer.
And it spills below his feet.
[Laughter]
-All over --
All over Michael Keaton.
-But it didn't hit him.
It was all over his feet
and I'm wondering now
if he knows that it was me
and he just ignored it.
Or if he was so mad that he just
let it go. I don't know.
[ Laughter ]
But it's a theme --
-But it's a theme for you.
And that sounds like something
that would happen to me.
-It's just so embarrassing
and of all people,
it's Michael Keaton.
-He's the greatest.
-He's the coolest.
-Yeah.
He's a good sport too.
Congrats on "Right Now."
-Thank you.
-I'm excited about this.
And you'll be performing
for us tonight.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Not only are you writing
and performing songs,
but you're also writing
and performing --
writing movies and plays.
Is that true?
-Yeah. Yeah.
So I started writing,
actually --
another connection we have,
is that one of the times
I came before,
we were talking about
gangster movies.
And I'm from Jersey and I hadn't
seen a lot
of these classic
Mafia movies.
-Oh, that was awful.
-So you were kind enough
to get me a gift basket
of all the movies.
And I watched them all.
Most of them.
-You did?
-"Sopranos."
-And I got so inspired
and it's close to home because
it's Jersey,
that I actually wrote a play
about the son of a wise guy in
Brooklyn, New York,
named Gino Castaluccio,
and we're doing our second
reading of the play next week.
-No way.
-Yeah. And so that --
and a couple films.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Dude, I love that.
-Thank you.
-I feel like
I inspired you.
-So I'm going to give you 50%
once we go on Broadway.
-No, no, no.
-It's only right.
-I just want a ticket to the
show. That's all I need.